[Music]
the Royals are celebrating Christmas a
little differently this year but first
we have to start with this viral moment
William and Kate teaming up for a
bake-off in the bbc's a berry Royal
Christmas special that aired on Monday
night but when will tried to put his
hand on Kate's shoulder he got a bit of
a Royal snub our source chalks us up to
the fact that unlike Harry and Megan the
spouses of eight years make a point to
keep the PDA to a minimum in public
events because they are the future king
and queen noting that although Kate's
brush-off was intentional it doesn't
indicate that anything's wrong between
the Cambridge duo the source says that
Kate's mindful that she was being
recorded by multiple cameras and just
wanted to remain professional adding
that the couple is happy in a good place
and devoted to their family and now for
a few holiday shake-up Prince George is
assuming a new role have a very happy
Christmas the Cambridge's were decked
out in their holiday best as they
arrived at Buckingham Palace for the
Queen's annual Christmas lunch on
Wednesday Kate Middleton showed up in
one car with her two youngest kiddos
Princess Charlotte and Prince Louis
whose hair seems to have gotten a lot
darker
Prince William arrived in a second car
with the couple's eldest son Prince
George sitting next to him in the
driver's seat this marked the first time
we've seen the six-year-old riding up
front
Prince Andrew also made a surprise
appearance at the lunch after stepping
down from his duties earlier this year
following his link to the late Jeffrey
Epstein noticeably absent where Prince
Harry
Megan Markel and their son Archie it was
previously announced that they're taking
some time to recharge and are spending
the holidays with Megan's mom Doria
Ragland the Sussex is haven't been seen
publicly since last month's Remembrance
Day events
so no annual photo-op of the Fab Four
arriving at church on Christmas this
year
but we're told there will be two tiny
new additions in their place a source
tells ET that Prince George and his four
year old sister Princess Charlotte are
expected to accompany the royal family
to Christmas at Sandringham for the
first time
the siblings have attended Christmas
services in Berkshire but this will mark
the first time they've walked to st.
Mary Magdalen Church with William and
Kate the source adds that things could
change but the current plan is for them
to join the royal family is all about
tradition and the way they spend
Christmas is no exception the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge have wanted to
raise their kids in is normal in
upbringing as possible our source says
adding that George and Charlotte's have
gotten used to the cameras on Royal
tours but understandably William and
Kate want to put their children's
interests first he's very cool when you
grow up especially in their life we grow
then you realize that there's light half
of your own parcels and speaking of
cameras the Cambridge kiddos had no
problem hamming it up for the annual
family Christmas Card
while the Royals haven't released the
official card on their social media
channels yet
lucky for us one recipient gave us a
sneak peek of the suite photo on Twitter
[Music]